let's talk a little bit about william
barr
william barr was the attorney general at
the end of donald trump's failed
presidential term
and william barr has basically turned on
trump but would probably still vote for
him over a democrat i know think think
that through
but william barr has now said listen all
of this stuff about privilege doesn't
make sense trump having documents at a
country club doesn't make sense none of
it makes sense and now it does appear as
though trump has fully turned on william
barr as well
sort of a deranged open mic night
feel at bedminster over the weekend
that's one of donald trump's golf clubs
and in what is just an absolutely
terrible terrible attempt at stand-up
comedy uh trump went after bill barr
basically by calling him fat saying all
he wanted to do was eat check this out
and i apologize for the poor audio
quality
[Music]
attorney generals that don't know how to
do their job
like billboard
is
[Music]
yeah what's crazier the things that
trump says like my attorney general was
fat
even though by the way trump doesn't
exactly look like he's missed too many
meals
or the fact that the cult members laugh
as if this stuff were funny as if this
stuff were fun both are kind of weird um
another clip this also i believe this is
also from bedminster but in a different
room or something
here trump is already suggesting that
sarah huckabee sanders who's running for
governor of arkansas and yes she's the
daughter of former arkansas governor
mike huckabee trump already is floating
that sarah huckabee sanders is going to
have the election stolen from her
due to this uh ubiquitous and
ever-present fraud you bought a trump
tie can you believe that
that right
and i said i love this guy
i love this guy but mike has been a
friend of mine from
the beginning and his daughter as you
know
i give janet the credit
i give him the
but and they're both here by the way two
incredible people but his daughter uh is
just an exceptional person yeah an
exceptional person and when you see what
they have right now feeding us the
information and then you compare that
with sarah
it's it's not even believable she was so
incredible and she took abuse and she
gave it back when necessary
but she took tremendous abuse and they
were nasty right from day one terrible
but there was nobody ever like her now
she's going to be well i mean we don't
want to talk there still is an election
in november mike right you know so she
still has to win it they say pretty
routine but there's nothing routine in
politics mike
you know maybe those votes don't come in
maybe they find a couple of million
votes like they did with us
there'll be a big dump at 302 in the
morning
in the state of arkansas more dumps
millions of votes will be found and she
will have lost by 100 votes now i mean
it's not going to happen but she uh but
she still does have an election so we
have to remember that but she's an
incredible person yeah now trump is
right it does seem like it's that george
the arkansas gubernatorial seems like
it's mostly going to be a formality
doesn't look like a democrat's going to
take that one but this is the constant
undermining of confidence in our
election systems and there's nothing
concerning happening in arkansas period
there's nothing concerning happening in
arkansas as far as the election goes
it's an extremely red state and sarah
huckabee sanders will probably win but
in some other places that are slightly
less red red but slightly less red we've
already seen democrats win and they
immediately say that there's fraud there
is no evidence of fraud it's that we do
have a unique situation where many
americans are completely sick and tired
of these republican nuts
you have many americans who are seeing
roe v wade
nothing done on gun safety
nothing presented as far as policy just
attacking democrats attacking liberals
on and on and on
and they're sick enough of it that
independents primarily but some
republicans are choosing to vote for
democrats and turning out in greater
numbers and so we've seen some
relatively surprising democratic wins
early so far and we will see what
happens in november
it's not even a question they're going
to do the voter fraud routine again it's
there's not not even a doubt sarah palin
has already done it in alaska kerry lake
did it in arizona um
interestingly
nobody's saying there was fraud where
liz cheney lost her primary in wyoming
very interesting i wonder why that is
incredible with years of fraud in every
race
suddenly the wyoming primary for liz
cheney was totally clean well what can
you do must be some explanation for that
but they're going to keep doing this
and it's it's totally plausible it will
again lead to violence at some point in
the future horrible stuff and they do it
so casually it's very anti-american